it's gonna be a trial run for a flight
to the fourth Rock From the Sun as NASA
prepares for a future manned mission to
Mars the agency plans to test several
astronauts living together in a Mars
habitat simulation for a year
but they're still calling it a manned
mission I wonder how long that's going
to last
they're also planning a future all-women
Mission if they can find it who can
parallel park The Landing module
no
four astronauts will be sealed inside a
1700 square foot NASA facility in
Houston in New York we call that a
mansion the custom built the
custom-built habitat dubbed Mars Dune
Alpha consists of four small rooms with
two bathrooms and like viewers of fox
and friends it appears the biggest
hurdle will be the sheer endless boredom
so
[Laughter]
so to keep these planetary Playhouse
Pioneers busy there's a gym a greenhouse
and even get this a brick making machine
which is what my wife called me when I
went on that vegan diet
it's a lot of sand there a lot of sand
there cat uh they make bricks out of but
you know what the issue is it's not
about the physical surroundings it's
like being around the same people for a
year who could you do this with
right yeah nobody no you know no
especially because it's going to be
strangers so like they're right they're
not gonna like send people who know each
other well I think all the there's not a
lot of astronauts they probably all know
each other right oh yeah they all like
hang out and go to happy hour there are
astronaut bars and stuff I think that
this what they should do they're missing
an opportunity to like make it a reality
show like they think they're just going
to Mars but actually their ex is there
they think they're just going to Mars
but like actually you have a son and
he's here yeah and he doesn't like that
he we want to talk about why you left to
you know the family all on this
spaceship for a year there's a lot that
Bravo could do with this here you know
what would be hilarious oh my God
Douglas what if would he be great great
if the experiment this experiment a year
thing completely mimics a trip to Mars
because it is one and they didn't tell
them
but they do figure it out at the end no
they don't because they just think
they're they just think it's a
simulation but they actually are going
to Mars and it's too late for them to
leave
it's
a brilliant plot it is that's brilliant
that's a movie that's not a reality
that's a movie call me Hollywood yeah
yep Hollywood I liked by the way when
you said the cat you know who would you
be able to be there with there was a
sort of look of longing in your eyes you
were hoping she was going to say yeah I
could live with you for a year Greg and
she didn't no you didn't I didn't say
that
but she didn't say anybody else so
there's still a chance it's a brick it's
a bricklaying thing true yes it is
really regarded as an important activity
yes a while away a year tell you why why
to build a wall around the other three
you stuck with
oh
here's a great question magger isn't
it Brits have never gone to the Moon
right you guys don't even have
astronauts do you guys have do you guys
have astronomy you you seem to know so
little I'm just gonna lie we go all the
time
it's like more common than a bust
Jim uh would you ever do this yes yeah
because it's close to your life really
right sure I mean I live in New York I
have a roommate I've done this yes uh no
I I wouldn't I I think I would uh but
the thing is you always know you have
the safety of just kind of walking out
if you have to right um I think it'd be
funny if they did send them to Mars but
they don't have a way for them to get
back yes well isn't that going to be the
essential plan there is no way back they
think they're going to send you and then
hopefully the thinking will be by the
time you get there they will have built
something that can actually get you back
which is very optimistic yeah it really
is
it's like when my parents dropped me off
in the forest no yes it's nicer than
what my parents did they just found a
van and said get in
Tyrus yeah I'm not doing this no how do
you poop you know I have to ask or like
even yeah like come on yeah of all the
Technologies Greg they didn't we ran out
of time to put a toilet in Greg
listen uh there's
I don't know why you have to practice
being alone just when you go to Mars
you're going to be alone I hate to break
it to you there's nothing there so
there's no air there's no water I'd work
on other things maybe try to get some
gills put in on or something but these
simulated tests I just think of the
movie Dr Frankenstein where once you go
in the other guy's just bound on the
door let me out let me out okay I did 15
minutes yeah this guy's weird it's a lot
I just it's a waste of money obviously I
spend a lot of money go to the moon go
fly around do something else but like
putting people in a box and videotaping
and catch right unless their ex is
showing up or their long-lost son or
something we're not going to watch it I
did
really send them to Mars yeah you got to
send them to Mars just don't just none
of the tell them it's a simulation send
them to Mars most expensive practical
joke of all time exactly yeah and not
even including the legal fees
this is when we this is I I'm Jim
Lampley is he still around I don't know
yeah hi I'm Jim Lampley this is we're
gonna tell them that they're actually
going to Mars
and they didn't know but instead they're
going to Fallujah
or Philadelphia
yeah I said Philadelphia what's the
problem
it's not like they're going to come
driving over here they don't even know
where I am I think I should probably go
to the next segment yeah this is dying
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else